[Music]
et has learned Pretty Little Liars star
Troian Bellisario is married I'm stoked
for it the 31 year old actress said I do
to her fiance soos actor Patrick Jay
Adams before exchanging nuptials Troian
took to Instagram on Saturday to share
her excitement about the couple's big
day posting this outdoor view from their
woodsy wedding weekend captioned today's
the day hashtag fort de 2016 her husband
also shared a sweet pic of the two
lovebirds smiling next to an almost
married bus well it comes as no surprise
that the pair is staying low-key about
their special day Patrick told et in
August that they plan to keep their date
under wraps and earlier this year the
bride-to-be played coy about rumors of a
winter wedding no truth to the rumors
that it's going to be by the end of the
year no no I just what I like I'm
constantly surprised that people like
care they're like are you guys getting
married and I'm like I mean essentially
we're like married like what does it
mean
[Music]
you